hi there i'm rayne wilson and i'm reza
aslan and rayne you know something that
you and i have in common besides being
both
sort of ridiculously handsome thank you
i knew you were gonna go there um
is that we're both rich
i mean i'm not i'm not like office
residuals rich but you know
we're both we're we're wealthy we're
wealthy we're wealthy sure um i don't
know if we're one percent i think i feel
like we might be the one percent i think
i'm definitely in the one percent i
think you're like two percent top three
for sure
welcome to metaphysical milkshake the
show where we go deep we get weird and
we search for the meaning of life along
the way presented by cast media and soul
pancake
[Music]
and that's true and the other
interesting thing about both of us is we
started off very poor
poor uh my family
was outrageously poor as i grew up i
mean
when i was a child we got powdered milk
because we couldn't afford regular milk
and i got my clothes at the salvation
army
up until maybe third or fourth grade
when we finally had enough money to kind
of get to go to jcpenney oh yeah oh yeah
welfare cheese welfare cheese that's my
experience of uh how do you make persian
cuisine with welfare cheese well what's
funny is we're not we're not even cheese
eaters but we would still take the
cheese it was like did you sell it and
on the equivalent of ebay you know i
should ask my mom what we actually ended
up doing with that cheese all i remember
is that you would open the refrigerator
and there would be like a like a
cardboard box of like just a big block
of cheese government cheese so how are
you doing being
wealthy now does this do you have guilt
white liberal guilt uh
yeah around your wealth like could you
brown liberal guilt do you struggle with
how you're
gonna give away the money or
you know i i think you know this week's
topic
that we're digging into is like
you know is money evil is it possible
for a rich man to get into heaven well
it's interesting that you say that
because
that of course comes from the famous
line of jesus's right that it's easier
for a camel to pass through the eye of a
needle
than for a rich man to enter
heaven which i think is another way of
saying
no
the answer is therefore no now i always
heard about that phrase that they were
referring to some gate or some pass
through the mountains that was called
the eye of the needle and it's very
difficult to get your camel through it
but it is possible to get your camel
through it yeah that's the
interpretation that a rich guy came up
with right so some rich christian in the
third century was like wait a minute
wait a minute wait a minute
but i guess the question that i have is
like why is it i mean you and i
have this kind of weird experience you
know not a lot of people go from you
know abject poverty to comfortable
wealth and we're both you know we try to
be good at least i try to be good i try
to help you know the world and you've
got charities and you know i work with
various um organizations
but
is it just about ameliorating my guilt
right is that what i'm doing is it like
a form of papal indulgence like okay
well i'll just keep making all this
money and like buying all this stuff and
then every once in a while just give a
little bit of money away and it'll be
fine you know so many systems in the
world are broken and dysfunctional
and not functioning and one of the main
ones is philanthropy
uh and if you work in the nonprofit
world you'll see this all the time
there's organizations chasing grants and
just kissing but to rich donors and
you know um
organizations that rent office space on
fifth avenue so you know a quarter of
their budget is going towards these
incredible you know offices to impress
the hoi polloi in new york city
organizations that have fundraising
galas
where you're looking around and like
this thing must have cost hundreds of
thousands of dollars
yes we're here amidst the champagne
fountain to raise money for the indigent
poor of africa and you're like what what
the [ __ ] are like how about spending a
little bit of this champagne money
on that although i will say that a good
chocolate fountain is definitely worth
it our guest for this week's episode is
going to challenge all of these sacred
cows and his name is reza ananger dardas
who among many other things has argued
that the rich giving billions in dollars
to philanthropy is basically a farce to
buy themselves coverage for all the bad
things that they do in the world uh he
uh is
he's gonna shake things up yeah i mean
he's caused some some real headaches uh
because
what he's doing is not just challenging
the idea of philanthropy he's just
challenging the whole
reason why we lionize these wealthy
people you know like everybody gives
you know jeff bezos and bill gates and
you know elon musk you know standing
ovations for giving away billions of
dollars in charity and anan is like
well thanks for the charity maybe stop
[ __ ] up the world instead like let's
start there so is there anything rich
people can do can rich people be good
can rich people be good can they do good
that's the question we're gonna ask
anand he's a journalist of course his
most famous book the thing that started
this entire conversation is winners take
all the elite charade of changing the
world
or as i like to subtitle it why rich
people suck
well this is right up our alley then
we're the rich people resenters
so uh let's see what he has to say
[Music]
it started to occur to me and i'm still
ashamed it took me a few years to maybe
really speak up but it started to occur
i forgive you
that these rich and powerful people who
are flying to aspen
to talk about making the world better as
i as i began to learn about their day
jobs i realized that before they got to
aspen they were causing the problems
they were flying to aspen to solve
um and at some point when i was asked to
give a talk there i called [ __ ] um
and the [ __ ] sort of went viral and
i expanded the [ __ ] into a massive
piece of [ __ ] called a book
and so here we are so
it's it's funny i mean i'm i want to
slow down for a moment here because
uh you said it took you a while to sort
of get it
and i totally understand what you mean
is it the reason that it took you a
while was it because i mean let's face
it like you know you're like in private
jets and you're hanging around with like
bill gates and you're like doing shots
with you know the koch brothers and
you're like this is kind of
fun and it's exciting you're like your
your perspective suddenly changes you
you start to when you become rich
adjacent right you start to see the
world in a different way and so yeah it
does take a while to suddenly peel back
the layers and realize
the vacuousness of the whole thing i
mean can can you can you sort of uh look
at yourself and and
kind of
recognize that that may have happened to
you that you may have sort of
you know drunk drunk the kool-aid a
little bit
100
so i think there was a seduction which
is what you're getting at which is true
and seduction buys silence and buys time
um but i think there was a a deeper
element which also gets to sort of the
the core of your show in a way
which is that
the aspen world that i was in
is suffused by a theology
and theologies are you know often
coherent
and and forceful and and also seductive
in a in a deeper way and and the
theology was
that we live in this new age of doing
well by doing good that you could change
the world um in ways that allowed the
people on top to keep profiting and
doing well that in fact the people who
had benefited most from an age of
cruelty were the best
architect
of the solutions to that age of cruelty
um that you could have your cake and
give it back too that we could come
together in aspen and and have goldman
sachs talk about empowering women
and that everybody in the room was
supposed to agree
that no one was to raise the fact that
goldman sachs would eventually plead out
to fraudulent activity that helped put
millions of women um on the street
and
and it was it was pleasant it felt like
you were part of this thing where people
were going to change the world
and eventually i woke up
it's a new year which means it's time to
leave behind the things that don't serve
you
like overdraft fees
when your checking account balances
running low the last thing you need is
an overdraft fee but with chime an
award-winning app and debit card you can
save that hard-earned paper without
paying overdraft fees eligible members
can overdraft up to 200 bucks on debit
card purchases and cash withdrawals and
listen there's absolutely no overdraft
fees make your first good decision in
2022 and join over 10 million people
using chime
sign up takes only about two minutes and
it doesn't affect your credit score you
can get started at chime dot com slash
milkshake that's chime c-h-i-m-e dot com
slash milkshake take it away rain
banking services provided by and a debit
card issued by the bancorp bank or
stride bank n a members fdic eligibility
requirements and overdraft limits apply
overdraft only applies to debit card
purchases and cash withdrawals limits
start at 20 and may be increased up to
200 dollars by chime see chime dot com
slash spot me
hey milk shakers are you looking to take
control of your health well a good way
to do that is to check good rx
and finally stop overpaying for your
prescription medications see listen
listen to me very carefully on this
prescription prices can vary between
pharmacies by as much as a hundred
dollars so
that means you're never sure what you're
going to pay or what you should be
paying so not only will goodrx find you
discounts it will also let you compare
and find the lowest prices at pharmacies
near you like cvs kroger even if you
have insurance or medicare goodrx often
beats your copay price
in fact anytime you need to fill a
prescription just checking goodrx could
save you up to eighty percent
taking control of your prescription
costs is free and easy with goodrx check
the website or download the free goodrx
app i mean i've got great insurance but
i also have like 15 kids
and there's always something wrong with
one of them
i mean the amount of money that i pay on
prescriptions
for these many many children
is outrageous and so i've i've started
just going to goodrx first before i go
to the pharmacy figure out like i mean
there's got to be a better savings here
and there almost always is
so for simple smart savings on your
prescriptions whether you have insurance
or not
check good rx go to goodrx.com
milkshake that's good
r the letter r the letter x dot com
slash milkshake goodrx.com milkshake
good rx is not insurance but can be used
instead of insurance in 2021 good rx
users saved an average of 79
on retail prescription prices
so let's let's take this way way way
back in the early days of humanity it
was seen that wealth was a gift from the
gods that the wealthy were more
connected to the divine that they were
kind of anointed in some special way
that's why they were wealthy that's why
they were wealthy because they were
essentially good people and righteous
people so they were given this wealth
and i think i mean that existed for
centuries i mean that sure existed for
centuries before the bible was written
how how do you see this kind of like
the the incessant need for humanity to
put the wealthy on these pedestals
it's such an interesting question and so
i think the way to answer that is
what i am describing in winners take all
is a
an ancient
eternal
um
tradition
that has a new particular inflection in
our time as it does in each time
right and so
to talk about the eternal part first
you're exactly right every ruling class
in history and it's not just wealth
right wealth is not has not always been
the
determinant of rulership right um and
for example i mean i have a
friend who's a very wealthy chinese
person
and he says you know it's interesting
i'm trying to have a lot of money i can
do a lot of stuff but it's very clear in
china i'm not in the ruling class
in america i would be in the right
interest in china i'm not because the
party rules china right um
and
so so there's always a ruling class the
eternal constant and the ruling class
always invents
a story of justification
so fast forward to now the question is
what is the particular inflection of
that story in our time because i think
only when we understand it can we
dismantle it and only when we dismantle
it does it as i say in the book become
possible again to
make the world better without permission
slips from the powerful the story in our
time i think
the story of justification
is that rich people
in an age of inequality that we live in
that everybody knows we live in
that rich people who might be the first
people we would suspect or resent
because obvious
age of inequality that those people
are philanthro capitalists that's a word
that sort of captures what i'm about to
describe those people are these
specially
gifted people who are brilliant capable
good at anything able to swerve into any
lane you start a social network because
you want to meet people at harvard in
the early 2000s now you're an expert on
public education
if you're mark zuckerberg and in
addition to being an expert on breaking
democracy and and
and you're just especially capable
super being
and and it's this idea that these people
are these super creatures
who are so capable of solving problems
in a way that you and me and democracy
are not simply because they're rich
no they're rich because of some other
quality they have that's the theory yeah
it's very the particular theory i'm
talking about today in 2019 is very much
about the entrepreneur specifically
right this is not about the ibm
executive who makes a million dollars a
year that person may fit into me like
kind of drag behind this theory but this
theory is really about the entrepreneur
hero and the theory of justification is
because these people are so capable of
solving any problem mainly their
business problems but then according to
this theory all problems
we must a leave them alone to make money
in whatever ways they can and we must
accept when they don't pay us enough
when they lobbied and distort our public
policy when they don't pay their taxes
we must accept this because they are
brilliant and then they're going to make
more money from doing those things than
they otherwise would have and then
with their extra money that they made
harming the society
they will then deploy
with their brilliant minds that money to
solve our biggest problems in ways that
no one else can we got to leave them
alone we got to leave them on top
because only problems that they can fix
problems that they mostly caused
and this is
the beginning the first important crack
in the armor that and at the heart of
the book
um in a way the project of the book the
thing michael lewis has this great line
about you know writers are people who
who think uh that the world is
fundamentally misperceived
some small thing and you try to fix the
world's perception of that
particular small thing the thing that i
felt the world had misperceived i mean
there were a few but the biggest one
was that the people who have been
branded as the great solutionists of our
age
are the people
who have caused
many many of these problems
and they caused them
not only in the most flagrant instances
doing crazy criminal things although
that happens that happens more than
you'd think
but almost all of them are complicit in
that plutocratic class in a few of the
following underpaying taxes avoiding
taxes evading taxes using
fancy accountants that you and i will
never be able to access to pay way less
to have big companies in america zero
offshore federal income taxes in a year
offshore etc that's one
lobbying
to distort public policy
if you are confident
that you are going to hack it in the
marketplace
under the rules of the democracy you
don't spend 20 million dollars lobbying
in washington it's only if you're not
confident that you're going to earn
money on your merits that you that you
do them
and and then third with regard to
workers finding every trick in the book
over the last 30 40 years a lot of these
new tricks over the last 30 40 years to
avoid paying people dynamic scheduling
making people independent contractors
and so
you know if you start to look at how
many people who have made
tremendous fortunes in our time
can certify
and and my email addresses on my website
can certify
that they have done none of those things
i would love to look at that list but
unfortunately i've left the conclusion
that the overwhelming majority are
complicit
in damaging the very society they would
propose to be the leaders of healing so
that's unbelievable that's one of the
greatest single monologues i've ever
heard in my life so thank you first of
all
um if i was going to argue devil's
advocate i'm going to be like i'm on fox
business news or something like that i'd
be like hold on tracy morgan called it
devil's avocado
[Laughter]
i yeah the devil's avocado i would say
well wait a second here now bill gates
created microsoft which created tools
that are now being used by
hundreds of millions of teachers all
around the world that help the ease of
communication and elon musk is advancing
technology he's employing hundreds of
thousands of people like these job
creators these entrepreneurs are
lifting all boats
by their their efforts and what they've
done and all of those people that
they're employing the the number of jobs
that they've created through you know
creating all these social media jobs of
you know tens of thousands of them that
didn't exist you know eight years ago
tens of thousands of social media
strategies strategists and uh and data
crunchers and and whatnot but that those
people now have money to give to
philanthropy and charity and to do good
in the world and that they've enabled
this so how how i'm sure someone would
have done a better job than i did
because i don't really buy it but what
what would be your answer to that
yeah it's a it's a it's an important
question one of the things i talk a lot
about in this book is the idea that a
successful society is a progress machine
it takes in a bunch of input activities
and it spits out broad human advancement
hopefully and on the first or second
page of the book i say america's
progress machine is broken everything
you described is all good stuff it's all
inputs it's inputs to the progress
machine right you invent
great tools for teachers to use
fantastic fantastic no one's denying
that we we live i say this all the time
we have lived in a golden age of
innovation right innovation is the latin
word for new [ __ ] and and we have lived
in a fertile period for new [ __ ] um and
i don't think anybody would say there
hasn't been enough in the last 30 40
years so someone like bill gates yes
invented tools and and i'm also not
denying that those did empower people
and those did i mean of course those
those did change the world um here's the
issue
all those things go into the progress
machine right and then you look at where
are we
as a society in a more fundamental way
at the end of that right
and
at the end of that bill gates in
particular in the 90s talked about how
this digital revolution he was
prosecuting was going to be a revolution
of leveling of social leveling and he
said my quote in the book what
hierarchies exist in the physical world
are kind of unrecognized by the digital
world and and the digital world will
serve to
to flatten those hierarchies well it
turns out that despite all that
innovation
and all the medical progress we've had
and new things discovered in that sphere
and all the new things that have
happened
power and wealth have grown more
concentrated
in the period you're describing of all
that new stuff um than they were before
it actually takes fewer billionaires to
account for half of america's wealth or
half of the world's wealth than it did
before all that stuff was invented
and so my argument is not that no one
was ever empowered by a pc sold by bill
gates that would be a preposterous
argument i am someone who was empowered
by a pc uh sold by bill gates and i'm
sure i'm not alone
the argument is despite
all that good stuff and we could keep
going on and on and on with the good
stuff despite that at the end of the day
when you actually look at the outcome of
the society
the society
power equations are in a worse place
than before and that those tools have
somehow served an agenda of
consolidation and concentration and and
i think if you if you
looked at this subjectively and you
actually ask people
about the level of control they feel
over their lives the ability they feel
to pass on a good life for their
children despite all the things that
bill gates and other people invented
those numbers have all gotten worse and
we have to take that seriously imagine
if there were microsoft equivalents in
india and china and germany and brazil
that had been able to you know and
the wealth could have been shared
instead of like all 100 billion dollars
of it amassed by microsoft as a as an
entity that that's that's actually a
very good point and and and you know it
may be that there are countries in
africa for example
that had they lived in a more
competitive tech
ecosystem in which microsoft was not a
monopolist might have produced tech
companies that would have ended up
paying corporate tax which as i was
reading this week is is often an
important disproportionately important
tax in certain african countries and
those countries may have been able to
provide malaria nets to their own people
um through the tax base if they had more
tech companies able to grow and
had not had that possibility eliminated
you know as soon as i wake up i'm on the
go i've got i gotta feed the kids i
gotta dress them i gotta like make their
lunches i gotta get them out the door
and then i gotta dress myself and get
into the car and i'm just like running
and running and the next thing i know i
turn around and it's time and i forgot
to eat
no wonder i'm so hangry all the time
but what are my options i mean i could
run through a drive-through grab
something that i know not good for me no
no thanks i don't need any more of that
in my gut but that's why i have fuel
fuel is human fuel application fuel
human fuel that's what it is it provides
all the carbs proteins fats fiber and 27
essential vitamins and minerals you need
in everything
is plant-based and they have a wide
range of convenient on-the-go options
for someone who wants to eat healthy but
doesn't have a ton of time like me rain
you're a huge hewlett fan you know i
love the huel reza and um
i just have a heel instead of breakfast
and it gets me through to lunch i feel
light i feel lean i feel mean 400
calories it's tasty i can sip on it
through the morning and it works out
perfectly for me
fuel is proof that fast food can be good
food i love it rain loves it and we
think you will too and right now you can
get free shipping on your first order
plus a shaker
and a free t-shirt go to huel.com
milkshake that's h-u-e-l-huel
dot com
slash milkshake and you can get free
shipping on your first order plus that
shaker and that t-shirt hewl.com slash
milkshake
[Music]
you hear that sound hear that sound rain
that is my beautiful bottle
of seed probiotics which i can no longer
live without fantastic tell us about
them well look you know i think people
think they know you know what probiotics
do and how how they work but i'm telling
you
that seeds daily symbiotic
is the real deal i mean not all
probiotics are created equal you know
that i know that
but this daily symbiotic is a broad
spectrum two-in-one probiotic
and a prebiotic
it's a proprietary formulation of 24
distinct probiotic strains in
scientifically studied dosages
proprietary engineered two-in-one
capsule that protects probiotics through
digestion to ensure delivery straight to
the colon folks it goes straight to the
colon rain okay
so listen you may have taken probiotics
before and you know probably never even
felt much of a difference it's probably
because the good bacteria wasn't even
surviving your gi tract seed is designed
differently
that's why it works it will also support
your gut barrier skin health heart
health micronutrient synthesis like all
those things that you don't really know
what they are but it just makes you feel
better
so people have seen improvements in
their digestion within 24 to 48 hours
and that includes bowel movement
regularity yes someone say poop
and eased bloating
so start a new healthy habit today visit
seed.com
milkshake and use code milkshake to
redeem 20 off your first month of seeds
daily synbiotic that's seed.com
milkshake and use code milkshake
so it's funny i love the idea of
thinking about this as a theology
because this really gets to the heart of
what i find to be your
uh most interesting
and and uh provocative
uh argument which is the whole problem
with the concept of charitable
billionaires right the the idea of the
giving pledge uh what what one of the uh
one of the billionaires who who is part
of the giving pledge referred to
recently as competitive philanthropy
because of course everything you know
has to be a competition among these
billionaires but you know warren buffett
uh donated 55 percent of his total
wealth bill gates has donated something
like 45 percent of his total wealth uh
bloomberg has given 12
um just we just found out not too long
ago that uh jeff bezos gave away two
billion dollars in 2018 and the problem
that that i see like encapsulated in
your argument
is not so much that okay these people
are giving away money sort of good for
them it's the way that they are lionized
for giving away these huge amounts of
money they're almost you know they
become sanctified it reminds
me a lot of the sort of old idea of the
papal indulgences right which is
since sin
and then just give some money and then
all that sin will just be completely
forgiven and
and and forgotten about and i remember
when the news came out about jeff bezos
i i think i saw a tweet of yours which
was like
you know okay well congratulations how
about just pay your [ __ ] taxes how
about that okay how about how about pay
your employees a living wage how about
that and then keep your two billion
dollars okay you know keep your [ __ ]
charity and actually
pay your employees a wage that allows
them to you know to to live to to to
subsist in many ways the giving that you
see right now is the symptom
of a winner's take all society that
gives very few people a virtual monopoly
on the future itself i think this is
very important what i think has happened
in american life is the people on the
top end of that gap
have monopolized the future when the
rain there has been going back to the
beginning of the conversation an
abundance of innovation of new [ __ ]
raining on this country over the last 30
40 years but when
that new stuff rained on america the
very few harvested most of the rain
water and what i am really talking about
is simply fixing the progress machine so
that when the reign of new stuff
falls on us in the future
most people's lives will get better
which is the actual and only meaning of
progress
so let's bring it back
to
the listener right now let's say
someone's listening and they're a school
teacher and they make 85 000 a year and
they're hearing all this conversation
about billionaires and income inequality
and philanthropy and and whatnot like
what are there any solutions any
messages that you have
for them or is this just simply an
awareness
raising consciousness raising kind of
conversation
it's a great question first of all
in that specific example if you're a
public school teacher listening to this
my guess is a lot of what i've said is
deeply familiar to you because you have
probably been if my if my past reporting
and people reaching out to me is correct
meddled with by all kinds of
billionaires already
in the last 10 years if you're a public
school teacher listening to this you've
probably had force down your throat
different billionaires curricular tools
you've had to use this facebook thing or
that microsoft thing as the condition
for your school
getting money so a public school teacher
listening to this actually like many
different types of people who might be
listening to this is not unfamiliar with
this actually because billionaires have
been so meddling in all aspects of
society that that very few americans
don't have contact with us but but to
the question of what can someone like
that do
i say to your school teacher and
everybody else think next time you see a
problem sometimes something you don't
like in your society that is a shared
problem think of solutions that have
four qualities public
democratic
institutional and universal that's good
solve the problem at the root for
everybody like pay your property taxes
instead of you know giving money for a
teacher to buy some crowns correct
[Music]
here's here's the fundamental question
uh that rayne and i are grappling with
uh in this episode is is a personal one
for us i mean rayne and i both
grew up poor
right we we know what it what it means
to to be on the other side of that gap
and now we're both rich
not like ultra rich not like flying
around in our own private jets rich
uh not in having like you know steaks
and vodka named after us rich although i
think you you have a vodka named after
you yeah but um
uh but you know rich
and
we both kind of like to think of
ourselves as good people people who who
care about the world and other people
and who want to do good in the world and
yet we're grappling with this notion
that
we
we are part of the problem like we're
part of this system here we're on the
other side of the gap and so
you know can can we be rich and be good
can we make money and do good at the
same time or is the process of making
that money
so inextricably tied
to
the rot within the system
that there is no other way
to to kind of um
disconnect ourselves from that but
there's no that it that whatever we do
from this point on is very much in the
guise of indulgences
there's a deeper question about
are you using
your place of privilege whether it's in
your business operations your creative
work
any giving back that you do are you
using that to accelerate
the dismantling of a bad system or are
you using it to shore up a bad system
and i think that is a very critical
point of difference you don't have to
not give that no one's telling you to
not give but there are some ways to give
that would
help certain people but but in a way
increase the resilience of the bad
system and there's other ways to give
they're going to start eroding it right
so let me take one
simple example
if you look at a lot of rich people
love the issue of education right now
right because it feels like a good way
to address inequality you can see the
kids you're helping if you donate and
the most you know the dominant way that
i see rich people getting involved the
people i've reported on for the book is
charter schools
and you get involved in the charter
school maybe you name the school you get
involved in the school as one of my
characters darren walker who runs the
ford foundation says to me in the book
you know then you can tell all your
friends you got three black boys into
yale and and it's a nice win-win
as we call it in the book it doesn't
hurt you and if anything and this is
sort of what bernie sanders got at when
he unveiled an education policy agenda
it actually keeps
your
white kids your rich kids safe in their
you know in their cloistered little
world because it
keeps minority kids and poor kids in the
charter school so you may be working to
make that better but it actually
preserves what sanders i think rightly
pointed out has sometimes become a new
kind of fancy separate but equal
system um so that's that's the kind of
change-making that does make a
difference in some people's lives but
actually tends to shore up a bad system
right it doesn't it's not changing who
has power it's not redistributing power
that same giver
could do another thing which they so
seldom do which is there are a bunch of
scraggly lawyers around this country
trying to win
what is effectively a brown v board
style
supreme court victory which will take
decades um to
make it illegal to fund public schools
by property tax
make it illegal for
one school to have 30 000 per pupil
spending and the school a mile across uh
yeah the way to have you know five
thousand dollars yeah i think we would
all i mean i've never met a conservative
who justifies that in principle so
that's that's an institutional pursuing
an institutional change that is much
greater than just supporting one
and by the way as in brown versus board
of education
one supreme court ruling and that
practice is illegal everywhere in the
land the next day
yeah right there are a bunch of lawyers
working on that
and i guarantee you
they have none of the millions flowing
to the charter school movement
right the walmart family is not giving
to them but they are giving charges
called betsy devos because all the
wealthy families benefit from the from
that exactly the the in the first form
of giving and this gets to your own
dilemma
it's a way of giving that fundamentally
preserves the system that allows you to
stay on top
and so it's change that changes nothing
it's fake change
the second kind of giving is giving that
puts your own privilege at risk is
willing to risk the system from which
you benefit for the sake of something
larger and that giving is possible too
and there are people who do it
and i think it is something whether you
are that public school teacher or you
both or real plutocrats it is it is
it is something that it is possible for
for everyone to reframe and shift and i
hope everybody reads the book will be
able to think about what that means for
them and apply it in their own lives
[Music]
okay it's lightning round time here we
go
describe your soul in 10 words or less
yes
what do you hope happens after you die
um that people will uh
you know look up my books in the library
do you pray
no but i'm but i'm looking into it
what's the one thing you know for sure
that the truth will win and the final
one the main one the one that we're most
concerned with
what is your life's big question
how best should we live
um that's a good one excellent excellent
answer excellent question
this has been like just mind-blowing and
awesome i'm so so glad we got a chance
it's really fun you guys are so
thoughtful i've been asked a lot of
questions over the last uh
few months but these are definitely the
best so thank you for your
thoughtfulness yay we win best podcast
yay
hey milkshakers uh as you know we love
to bring you on the show you can write
us on social media you can also
leave a good review
on apple podcasts and we will find you
and bring you on with your life's big
searing question now we've got connor
connor you're from arizona
yep that's correct okay well what is
going on with you what's on your mind
yeah i have a lot on my mind so
what i'm thinking about today is in a
world that is increasingly complex and
intertwined and there's so many things
that are connected and kind of affect
each other now how can a person know
what is an ethical decision
um and how can they you know is that
something that changes with time or how
is that something that you can even know
nowadays
oh yeah i mean absolutely right rain
absolutely
but that's true of both ethics and
morals which of course if you've had a
college course in either you know or two
different things right ethics are like
the rules of society right like the
rules that society and morals are
universal norms yeah norms of behavior
and stuff like that and morals exactly
individual
uh you know more universal and hell yeah
they both change as as the the world
changes not always for better by the way
um
but uh but you know if if
ethics are supposed to be a reflection
of society if you don't if you believe
that society changes then you have to
believe that ethics are malleable and
that they're constantly
changing you know we're we're in a war
now uh where there's a big war happening
uh obviously and this has got us all
thinking about this stuff i imagine this
is where this is coming from conor
everything is just so complicated these
days
and i just think man
i know this is kind of a cop-out
but
to kind of scrap the philosophy and just
go right to the spirituality like it's
all about loving kindness man
it's all about loving kindness
and
i've been listening to a lot of these
near-death experiences on youtube
there's thousands of people relaying
their near-death experiences and it's
absolutely incredible how there are
these universal concepts that happen in
each one but it all comes back to like
be more loving be more loving be more
kind in everything you're doing that
that's what you remember that's what you
honor that's what you cherish
and
that's what they seek to do when they
come back from these near-death
experiences so
i know that's kind of shifting the
conversation but this has been on my
mind a lot so yeah for me it's
how can we simplify it just go to love
baby i think that's a great answer
that's it that's it that's all we got
we solved his problem i can expound on
that sorry i didn't want to cut into no
no please
no i think that's a great answer
um i'd agree because there's just again
so many things that
you can over complicate it almost when
you when you try and get into the weeds
of it a bit i think so really reducing
it down to
am i loving those people you know right
around me and am i loving people to the
best that i can with my decisions i
think that that is
i mean yeah what more can you really do
at a certain level
yeah when it gets right down to it that
can be your guide and it will never let
you down and it doesn't matter you can
be atheist or you can be catholic or
jain or
muslim or uh wiccan it doesn't really
matter connor from arizona thanks for
calling absolutely thanks for having me
guys we love you milkshakers
well love is a strong word no it's love
it's all about love i love you rezza
i love you too right
metaphysical milkshake is executive
produced by rayne wilson reza aslan and
colin thompson it is produced by safa
samasa de yaz harris lane mick demaria
hashem himself and dj lubell
metaphysical milkshake is produced by
amy s choi and rebecca lehrer of the
mashup americans associate producers are
jocelyn gonzalez lindsey crowell sarah
pellegrini mary phillips sandy and
shelby sandlin original music by jeff
tang and scott tang
[Music]
hey by the way there's something that uh
anand and i both have in common which is
that neither of us will ever be invited
back to the aspen institute what's the
aspen institute
that's what he was talking about where
all the like the rich white people
around the world get together and talk
about how awesome the super elite yeah
[Music]
hey thanks for watching you guys for
more fantastic videos just like the one
that you watch please subscribe to our
youtube channel thank you